[Applause]
the reason why it's a big stat
is because he gets to the line nine plus
times
a game right at the top
milwaukee a one-point lead
and he honest this is the first
we know there's going to be a lot of
attention on exactly this throughout the
bucks playoff run
adeta kumbo at the line especially late
in games
anytime you get there nine plus times
and you shoot only 68 for the season
you know that there's not a great deal
of confidence on the line
is four for eight today
[Applause]
and i think we may have a lane violation
we do did they or would it be a
10-second violation
i believe that's right giannis took more
than 10 seconds this is something that
many teams have pointed out at the end
of the regular season
the officials aware of it and giannis
loses the free throw attempt because he
took more than 10 seconds butler gets
hammered by lopez it's a very difficult
thing to put him back on the line
but give him the credit because he
continues to go in there
against two and three guys and accepts
the physical contact
massive free throw here for giannis to
make it a three-point game
[Applause]
can't get it to go loose ball grabbed by
ariza